ahora si le supera otro récord cuatro
mil 249 muertes en 24 horas y se acerca
peligrosamente a los 350.000
fallecimientos desde el inicio de la
pandemia se cumplen así las peores
expectativas de los epidemiólogos que
temen que brasil pueda superar los 5 mil
muertos diarios mientras y con una
pandemia fuera de control
el presidente y jair bolsonaro sigue
repitiendo que no va a haber un local
nacional los médicos de todo el país
exhaustos denuncian escasez de
medicamentos para incubar a los
pacientes y también lamentan la falta de
una coordinación nacional en la lucha
contra la pandemia además de los
próximos 10 días 1200 ciudades de brasil
podrían quedarse sin oxígeno entonces
veríamos de nuevo aquellas escenas
terribles de inicio del año en manaos
cuando decenas de pacientes se morían en
los hospitales y en la lista de espera
asfixiados pero no todas son malas
noticias estamos ahora en serranos
una ciudad del interior del estado de
sao paulo donde el instituto butantán
está llevando a cabo un experimento sin
precedentes vacunar al 97% de la
población adulta de esta ciudad para
determinar así si la vacuna china es
eficaz para reducir los contagios las
muertes y las complicaciones serrana es
en este momento la esperanza de brasil
un país que además enfrenta una
proliferación de mutaciones del corona
virus